Lorenzo Appena sveglio
non c'è niente di così male dai
[Musica]
ciola sta facendo le storie se ne fotte
cioè del video proprio non te ne frega
Io sto lavorando Scusa puoi fare il tuo
il tuo coso e non fare la storia ciao
hanno fatto per il trentesimo di
Disneyland Paris la forma di Topolino
col 30 quindi chi è stato a fare questa
cosa qua è un genio vorrei che lavorasse
al posto di Giampiero
ragazzi Wow
da invidiare ai grandi parchi cioè io
sono stato anche tipo quello in Giappone
Niente da invidiare bellissimo
No sembrano veri
grandi fai una foto e il video
pazzesco la riproduzione incredibile dei
Pantellas
Sai qual è la cosa divertente di tutto
questo è che essendo in Francia in tutto
quel casino lì non c'è neanche un bidet
sfidiamo a guardare la partita della
Juve anche mentre fai l'attrazione ok
cioè Juve - Milan e j-ax bravo bravo
durante la partita si si stavano la
partita Eccolo qua
Guido eroe Il bello
questa parte Juve Milan questo è tu
arrivi in cima e poi fai questa
dondolata dall'altra parte tutto nel
mentre che guardi Juventus - Milan
Bravo Gian bravo bravo bravo
Quanto fa la Juve J quanto fa
Guarda che quelle fuori gioco è il
fuorigioco
bellissima è stata finalmente Giampiero
ci ha ripreso Beh
ma
chi è che sto pagando per lavorare
[Musica]
c'ho fame pronto ma io ho una fame la
Madonna pizza Bravo
[Musica]
Sono sono bello Sei bellissimo Adesso
deve partire la parata di Halloween dove
fanno vedere i personaggi del terrore
quelli di Halloween
ad esempio Eccomi
[Musica]
cacchio
no
E allora fai tutto quello che vuoi di me
Stai calmo devi stare calma calma
sono personaggi
[Musica]
stiamo per incontrare uno dei più grandi
idoli della mia infanzia tu non ti
perdono un attimo che questo è
importante per me è importante Io ti
giuro Ho i brividi anche Jacopo guarda
Nel senso che dobbiamo camminare è
entrato muoviamoci Allora muoviamo e
stiamo entrando nel padiglione delle
principesse cioè quello che aspettavo di
più come mai perché mi piacciono i film
delle principesse il tuo preferito tra
Rapunzel ho capito Andiamo però sono più
esaltato che da Topolino Ok come sto
vediamo Ok a posto
il nome A me me l'ha chiesta io ho detto
Allora gli sta dicendo Ah iPantellas e
poi fanno la foto Voglio andare via e
schiacciare il pulsante rosso
[Musica]
non mi ha fatto fare un cacchio Eh
infatti la grande verità che Lorenzo ha
smesso di fare Gameplay perché è scarso
mio gioca a Slender me ne ha Cat Mario
Basta ok Non riesco a fare politica
punti Falqui umiliato
faccio cagare Veramente sono
impegnatissimo
e quindi questa uscita a Disneyland
Paris è finita È stato tutto molto
interessante tranne il fatto che
purtroppo il Milan ha vinto 2-0 Milan
vince 2 a 0 quindi mi sa che questa
questa attrazione peggiore per il nostro
Iacopo Per il resto meraviglioso non c'è
stato bellissimo veramente incredibile
Ciao
brividi